well we thank you for your nominations
of some 80 wonderful women across
southern nevada and we have chosen our
four remarkable women to honor this year
and today we want to introduce you to
the final and fourth kathleen miller
as a woman of faith she's had many
different callings during her lifetime
but she says none as impactful as the
help that she's offered to some 600
young women over the past 15 years with
her non-profit living grace homes
kiersten joyce shares her story this
morning
kathleen miller moved with her husband
monty and their family to las vegas in
1994. she started volunteering with
church and community outreach groups to
protect women in crisis pregnancies at a
time when las vegas had the highest teen
pregnancy rate in the country people
would come up to me and say kathleen
what we really need here is a home for
pregnant moms
years passed and when she realized
nobody was stepping up to fill the need
she took it upon herself in 2007
kathleen opened living grace homes a
safe haven for young women from life
storms i don't think that when we opened
the doors that i anticipated
the ways that we would impact young moms
lives she also didn't realize how much
trauma these women would have suffered
by the time they walked through her
doors our population
is young women who have been abused
neglected and oftentimes abandoned
and so what our role has then turned out
to be
is to help
fill in those missing pieces
that they didn't get when they were
children growing up the dining room
is like most homes the hub living grace
is comprised of two homes a non-profit
open to homeless teens and women aged 14
to 25 who are pregnant or have young
kids kathleen helps them get their
diploma eventually employment moving
young women from dependency to
empowerment if we can can make sure that
there's a roof over their head a warm
shower
a
warm bed a shoulder to cry on and i
always say in a pointy toes shoe to kind
of give them a kick in the in the rear
to to send them back out and start
working on finishing school and getting
a job then
their life of their child becomes their
primary focus
in 2019 living grace received
henderson's outstanding non-profit of
the year designation and while executive
director has been kathleen's title for
the past 15 years her most important
role was house parents they knew me as
the person that told them when to go to
bed at night when to get up in the
morning when to clean the room
um
and in the last couple of weeks i've
heard from three of them
that have stopped by to just to say
hello to check on me to let me know how
they're doing she does an incredible job
you know they take the girls to their
appointments they educate them they they
really give them a chance to turn their
lives around we ask that you bless this
food that we're about to receive this
past holiday season we had the chance to
join kathleen and some of her residents
during a christmas celebration at living
grace this will be my first
christmas where i wasn't alone caitlyn
shaw a mother of three her youngest son
just a few months old it feels like kind
of like a family and i'm something i've
never really had before being able to
support their own family unit is
kathleen's ultimate goal for these young
women it seemed to be that that was what
i was being called to do
wow wow man think of how many lives she
has touched and changed forever
remarkable and just seeing a need in the
community and stepping up and saying
well no one else is doing it
i'm going to do it and doing it and
executing and doing such a great job
it's fantastic
congratulations and i feel like if she
says it's time to she was talking about
telling the the families that are going
to go to bed and like you know be i feel
like i'd listen to her
she means business she's got a little
mom going on yeah